how do you know the beaver what's going  on dude we're actually good friends is  that right yes you hang with it I've  hung out would be no kitty what do you  mean you hung out would be we're friends  like it's not it's not a fictional thing  is he going to the wedding  Bieber will be Wow he's invited I don't  know if he'll be there but beep of  course man  [ __ ] better get up and sing something  that's it Bieber is a is a great guy  here hears nothing about be nobody else  relax yeah tell me you cannot throw that  type of success in money at a person at  that young age and expect them to  survive it free and clear they're going  to make mistakes so when he eggs a house  or something we should give him a little  bit of leniency because famous when I  was 14 y'all saw some of the dumb [ __ ]  that I did you could see Kevin Hart and  ride along to opening this Friday  January 15th and theaters everywhere